si on a plusieurs raz de marée chez on
n'est pas certifié bio mais je fais tout
comme
cathy guillemette a acheté cette petite
ferme il ya deux ans elle élève entre
autres 300 poulet de grain par année
qu'elle doit envoyer dans un abattoir
industriel
ça prend souvent quand tu es minimum on
les amène tous si nous mettent ça sur un
crochet cespa standardisés qui on vient
les chercher l'emmener
c'est un peu dommage quand même que moi
qui ai artisans fermiers g pauvre la
possibilité d'être impliquées dans le
processus elle aimerait beaucoup
diversifié sa production ce qui est un
peu compliquée pour le moment aussitôt
qu'on parle d'oiseaux un peu plus rares
comme la pintade même le canard à la
limite c'est de plus en plus difficiles
à trouver des endroits pour leur faire
faire reste réapproprier notre terroir
mais y'a pas à l'abattoir mais les
choses sont en train de changer et enfin
là c'est concret et on peut vous faire
visiter notre infrastructure
la productrice doit fernande wallet
travaille depuis plus de trois ans à
développer le petit abattoir ici on est
dans l'inde arrive et lui vend à cet
abattoir si on recevra tous types de
volailles et des la tête
la coopérative a reçu sa certification
cette semaine et elle va commencer ses
activités en nous avec les dizaines de
travailleurs à la fin du cycle
d'échaudage on prend les oiseaux on les
envoie vers la rue meuse à sa vitesse de
croisière l'installation devrait traiter
environ 800 poulets par jour ou un peu
moins s'il s'agit d'oies ou de canards
d'adapter notre rythme de travail puis
notre hauteur de travail aussi très
rassurant je sens
de l'adapter soit à l'espèce à l'âge des
oiseaux ou différentes
grosse heure qu'on peut rencontrer
suivant les conduites d'élevage
l'achat et l'aménagement des cinq
conteneurs a coûté plus de huit cent
cinquante mille dollars dont la moitié
en subventions gouvernementales
lui même ancien producteur le maire a
soutenu le projet dès le départ faut pas
penser que c'est face à peut être faite
je sai heures on a accepté de le faire
chez nous avec les contraintes qu'on a
quand même exiger le port au niveau de
la santé au niveau de certains
paramètres mais [ __ ] dans l'idée qu'il
fallait que ces entités l'existant
quelques pas géniaux
qui permet d'obtenir le résultat
lorsqu'on novartis est pas un abattoir
c'est un outil de développement rural le
pari qu'on fait c'est que si on le bâti
autour l'agriculture va se développer et
l'agriculture de subsistance aussi donc
c'est la marche vers l'autonomie
alimentaire par le biais des
infrastructures elles rêvent déjà que le
modèle soit repris dans de nombreuses
régions d'abord ce qui est important ce
que ce projet là réussissent mais après
soeur pour la possibilité d'avoir un
autre quelques autres projets similaires
sur le téléphone québec ça prend une
masse critique de clientèle de produits
à transformer son successeur qui peut
être complexe on regarde peut-être faire
une table champêtre éventuellement cathy
guillemette elle planifie déjà la
diversification son élevage ça
changerait matoussi c'était pas du petit
abattoir nom plein d'enfants il change
complètement puppy miser surtout donc
pourrais je fasse quelque chose de
différent
il reste à espérer que la grippe aviaire
qui prend de plus en plus d'ampleur au
québec ne viendra pas trop bouleverser
les plans de la coopérative d'abattage
c'est marie claude morin radio canada
s'est joint venture